hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to just at
the height of Batman the enemy at series
popularity warner brothers decide to do
a spinoff with superman using a lot of
the same people and that show seemed to
do well enough that for its next season
and Batman's fourth they decide to
combine both of them together in the New
Adventures of Batman and Superman but
that wasn't the only surprise people
were given Batman went through some
seriously noticeable changes including
new designs new characters and just an
all-round new feel it was still the same
animation same voice actors but the
evidence was clear this was a different
Batman than what we saw three seasons
before season four or the red sky series
as I call it was very controversial at
least among fans some say it was a
welcome change of pace others say was
trying to fix something that was never
even broken whatever the reason for the
changes it of course invites the
question what season for a hit or miss
from a character set up we still have
the same backstories only some of them
have moved on since we last saw them we
see that Dick Grayson is fed up with
being Robin ax has moved on to being
Nightwing even Robin to be placed by
another orbit only half his age this
time named tin drink it's nice to see
Grayson go rogue and finally develop his
own badass persona but it's still
strange to see Bruce Wayne take someone
even younger now under his batwing as
Robin this guy has to be worth parent of
the year but you could argue that's the
leeway of comic books and even the idea
of the original Robin took a pretty big
suspension of disbelief to begin with
plus I surprisingly like this kid he's
got a lot of energy he's smart on his
feet and he gets some actual funny
one-liners here and there
playing hooky it's summer vacation never
mind
forgot who I was talking to batgirls
prominent in a lot more episodes as is
the penguin only this time around he has
his own establishment running upscale
parties at his nightclub while still
partaking in evil schemes on the side
this isn't such a bad idea seeing how
his intelligence does indicate he would
be smart enough to know how to pull it
off the rest of the characters are
pretty much the same that is of course
except for those controversial designs
yep let's talk about what many consider
the most
our indifference in all the season the
characters and makeovers the whole style
of the show has gone more angular
resulting in everyone looking less
three-dimensional and more um pointy but
one can make the argument that's kind of
what they were going for it to begin
with
I mean Batman's chin does look like the
bottom of a box doesn't it so here you
could say that just going all the way
with it plus the red sky and blacker
backgrounds did help the color stand out
even more so the characters actually did
pop out whenever they were on-screen but
subtle changes to characters like Alfred
or two-face aren't major issues but huge
changes to characters like Catwoman and
the Joker are so let's go over them
briefly
Batman has gotten rid of the yellow on
his symbol which I'll admit I do really
miss but to be fair it did sort of look
like a bull's-eye not the best nightly
camouflage but on leave that doesn't
stop Batgirl from changing into bright
yellow cape gloves and boots oh yeah
you'll blend into the shadows much
easier that way at first I thought this
was a pretty silly chain seeing how the
original costume helped her to hide in
the night a lot more but the more I
looked at the original costume the more
I realized it deep just sort of look
like Batman's kastri amount of college
girl and nothing else distinctly unique
about it but maybe this would help give
her a little bit more of an identity
plus if that may still dress as his
adopted son as a neon fire hydrant I
guess the same kind of bizarre logic and
work here to penguin was an odd callback
to the design of the 60s but again if
they want him to run a ritzy nightclub
it makes more sense he would look a
little bit more sophisticated strange as
it is though I have grown more
accustomed to that upscale voice coming
out of this monstrous designed and I
have this one that's probably more
fitting haven't you heard
I've reformed $50,000 for the diamond I
think I'm just too used to it our femme
fatale certainly looked darker that is
well Harley has few two note changes
both Catwoman and poison ivy have
prominently blacker toned costumes and
paler skin this results in them looking
more threatening and badass but I will
say that me will just a touch too young
in the original there was no Miss
that these were women maybe in their
late 20s or early 30s but in the
redesign they look more like college
students maybe around bad girls age I
know they're not meant to but it still
sir it comes across characters like croc
Scarface and the Mad Hatter look pretty
cool but they do sort of look like they
should be on a different show again the
emphasize features might be just a touch
too emphasized they almost look more
like Animaniacs characters and then you
have the Joker um how do I put this he
looks terrible honey God Jesus what have
you done to all of all the ways you
could redesign arguably the best Batman
villain of all time it seems like this
intriguingly takes every wrong step the
Joker is Batman's opposite he's a bright
loud colorful clown
so why suck out all the color from his
face and give him black expressionless
eyes yeah I know a lot of designs were
doing this at the time and I still don't
get why he looks less like a Batman
villain and more like a dancing prop
from Steamboat Willie I don't think it's
any coincidence that on the DVD when
they talk about the redesigns of all the
characters they smartly leave out the
Joker my guess is they probably gotten
enough complained about already so much
so that when the spin-off movie return
of the Joker came out they went back to
a design much closer to the original it
was definitely a welcome for attorney
for all the bitching that could be made
about the Joker in my opinion it all
evens out with the redesign of the
Scarecrow holy shit where did this
freakiness come from this is one of the
best designs the show has ever done that
calm neutral voice that only sounds so
much scarier coming out of those skull
liked heat tears the glue that holds
society together
fear is power mmm even if yeah
technically he looks absolutely nothing
like a real-life scarecrow think he
looks freaking creepy am i clock three
designs are one thing how did the actual
stories play out a lot of them try to
focus on the creation of new villains
some of them work like a hyper super
human who are you
they call me yellow-skinned wacky man
but I prefer them creeper a masked
beauty who thinks she's deformed and
another creepy Edition called the judge
Court is a jerk
while others kind of seemed out of place
like this redneck farmer who grew
mutated animals or this ancient demon
boy who uses a supernatural artifact to
control a giant monster I get the
feeling these would be good in something
else but here it's a little odd even for
Batman there's a few stories that seemed
a little odd too like this one episode
where Clayface returns and creates a
little girl to scout the area to make
sure he can take shape again the girl
somehow has a personality of her own and
forms a friendship with Robin until she
remembers who she is and she has to
return to Clayface yeah creating another
awareness out of clay seems like a bit
of a stretch but then again it does
prove to be one of the more touching and
even darker episodes in fact a lot of
them get a lot darker than before we can
interesting dive into an abusive
relationship with Harley's backstory a
funeral for Batgirl right after seeing
her fall to a pretty gruesome death and
even the Joker gets axed off after
mentally torturing and brainwashing
Robin to be his psychotic spawn as I
said before though darker doesn't always
mean better for example in mr. Freeze's
return he loses hope and humanity and he
even loses the majority of his body to
his disease resulting in an ending up as
I was hoping to see you again
oh Christ that is beyond fucking stupid
this is Marvin the Martian science guys
I what am I looking at before every
episode that tries something new that
doesn't work there's another one right
around the corner that try something new
and succeeds one especially fun one is
where three kids share their stories
about what they think Batman is like
displaying the different interpretations
that Batman has had over the years they
even take a pretty heavy hit at
Schumacher as one of the kids named Joel
has his own strange fixation on the Dark
Knight I love that man all those muscles
the tight rubber armor in that flashy
car I heard it can drive up walls
yeah sure Joel out the fourth season
also like to combine characters a lot
teaming up Nightwing with Catwoman croc
with baby doll and even a few Superman
crossovers here and there
this created combinations we've never
seen before making for interesting
interactions in a strange way this make
Gotham seem much more like a community
where the relationships of the
characters was what drove the stories
forward so with all these elements
combined how this season four hold on
well it's give and take
well the suspension of disbelief was a
beauty did often result in darker
stories while some redesign were wildly
questioning others were incredible
upgrades while many stories were goofy
and out of left field
others proved that they still understood
the dark tragic journeys of some of our
favorite characters so as a whole before
season is probably not the strongest but
it doesn't deserve to be overlooked or
ignored
I admire these guys for taking chances
and trying something new even if all the
changes didn't pay off Batman has gone
through so many interpretations over the
years and this is one of the few times
we get to see the exact same team
reinterpret themselves in a different
way
that doesn't happen very often and it
allows a chance for artists and writers
to come at something they obviously love
in a completely new light so an answer
to is the four season hit or miss I'd
say it's both hit and miss but the hits
are still strong enough to give you the
chills when the bat signal hits the sky
and the Caped Crusader takes to the air
and as long as I can always get that
feeling while watching it I'll know that
always watching the right Batman I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it because
I'm Batman I love this mask
you